walking out masks on these students
protest the end of a mask mandate in
ontario schools our group has pushed for
access for a 95 mass pursuit that's not
happening it's an equity issue so as
others masks come off i feel the need to
upgrade coven might spread again and we
don't want to see the numbers rising
once scientists are approved for this
decision i will be safe in children who
are average risk
we really don't have the data to tell us
that this is an important you know
measure this family doctor and former
child and family therapist says there
isn't enough science neither on how well
masks actually work to stop the spread
in the classroom nor on long-term
development and social impacts kids need
to watch
sound um and vowel pronunciation coming
from their teacher's mouths and when
they can't see that it affects their
ability to to learn how to read right
and these are skills that are meant to
happen at certain developmental stages
ontario is the sixth province to drop
school mass mandates this month bc will
follow after spring break pei and the
yukon still require masks in school so
do nova scotia nunavut the northwest
territories and newfoundland and
labrador but that may change in the next
few weeks meanwhile in the u.s hawaii
remains the only state with a classroom
mass mandate the risk of severe illness
for children with kovid remains very low
hospitalizations do remain a fairly rare
outcome and probably on par to what we
might see during a bad influenza season
and and yet we don't mandate mask
wearing for influenza but after wearing
a mask in the classroom for so long
opinions are mixed about taking them off
and not everyone will i'm so happy
because myself i didn't like wearing
masks you feel comfortable i'd like you
to still stay in your mask and they were
quite happy about it i think the masks
are actually developmentally
not great so i think it's time
change can be tough for kids and experts
say for some this was bound to be a
difficult day no matter the decision
abigail beeman global news ottawa